Our student just learned Java.
>> That's amazing.
>> It's huge.
>> It is huge.
They also learned how to
add a button on the app.
Click on the button,
something happens magically.
It's called event-driven programming.
>> Oh, yeah.
>> You know it, we know it,
they know it, now.
>> Yeah, now they know it.
And we also learned about variables.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Which is what makes the quantity
picker go up and down.
>> Correct.
Alice, the Android developer,
made a guest appearance.
>> Oh yeah, Alice.
>> She was talking about how she gets
unstuck when she comes across a bug.
>> Mm-hm.
Those are some good tips.
>> Right.
>> Yeah.
>> So, do you know what that means?
>> We're basically done.
>> We're done with lesson two.
>> Nice.
>> You done with that?
>> Yeah.
>> I think so.
>> because we closed an hour ago.
>> Oh, sorry.
>> I'll take it from here.